soir à tous merci d'être là c'est on ne
va pas se mentir on parle ce soir du
front national le front national voilà
l'ennemi c'est ce que dit manuel valls
maison en désignant ainsi la cible et de
ces attaques et en revendiquant la
stigmatisation du national le premier
ministre en fait-il trop dans la
perspective du scrutin départemental
d'ailleurs comment le front national est
il devenu le centre de toutes les
attentions un peu comme si ce scrutin
devenait un référendum pour ou anti fn
nous poserons la question à nos invités
ce soir qui défendent d'autres couleurs
politiques
la carte et le bâton ou l'art de la
synthèse par françois hollande alors que
dans les colonnes du journal challenge
il explique qu'il n'entend absolument
pas changé de cap ni de politique bien
le chef de l'état reçoit ce soir une
délégation de députés frondeurs pour les
rassurer les câliner leur donner la
sensation d'être écouté et puis une
nouvelle attaque personnelle de
l'opposition entre christiane taubira
resserre un peu plus des rangs du
gouvernement derrière la garde des
sceaux isabelle guinot première adjointe
au maire ump de juvisy sur orge dans
l'essonne sans étiquette a estimé que
puisque christiane taubira via de
cayenne où il y avait un bagne elle
pourrait bien y retourner manuel valls
et françois hollande ont exprimé leur
indignation
pour nous en parler autour de cette
table et parler aussi de leur propre
thème leur propre combat à nant à la
perspective du scrutin départemental
nous recevrons isabelle bordry bonsoir
mon sens résidente de nous citoyens
corinne lepage bonsoir présidente de
cap21 marque fait ce ne soit mon joueur
secrétaire général du modem et raquel
garrido bonsoir et soir parole
international du parti de gauche vous
pouvez également réagir via twitter avec
le mot diez om vs m mais je précise que
ce soir nous avons une version réduite
dont on ne va pas se mentir en raison du
match de foot et doit mi temps et de
l'expertisé de pascal praud de ses
invités à propos du match entre chelsea
et le psg au bouton entre le psg et
chelsea
ce soir alors on va commencer par et
bien ses attaques à l'égard du front
national cette attaque frontale menée
par manuel valls depuis une quinzaine de
jours et considère que l'ennemi de la
démocratie finalement dans ce scrutin
c'est le front national il a indiqué sa
peur que la france se fracasse contre le
front national et ce matin la garde des
sceaux christiane taubira affirmait que
le front national mehenni a party
républicaine est parti démocratique
écouter ce qu'elle en dise est une
écoute la réaction de nicolas du pontet
et puis pas d'aller aux élections pour
être un parti républicain il faut
accepter d'abord les valeurs de la
république je conteste aussi bien sa
nature républicaine que sa nature
démocratique et conteste toutes les deux
et je le démontre il suffit pas de
profiter de venir parasiter les
avantages et les protections de la
république pour être républicaine
est ce que la ministre de la justice est
allé trop loin ce qu'elle est dans la
sphère noël seront pardon j'ai écorché
votre notre valeur est ce qu'on fait mal
en mettant comme ça le front national au
centre du jeu oui parce que je pense que
ont nourri un système qui s'auto nourrit
d'une certaine façon ou et c'est vrai
que le système médiatique en parle mais
c'est vrai que le premier ministre y
contribue largement puisque depuis
quinze jours c'est la tactique il a
choisi moi je considère que c'est quand
même un peu un aveu d'impuissance et
d'un aveu d'impuissance de tous ceux qui
en parlent dans ces termes là alors
après parti républicain en partie des
mots critique ou pas il ya des lois et
des règles dans le pays et dans la
république c'est un parti qui
aujourd'hui est autorisé il ya eu des
partis qui avait dérivé ils ont été
interdits il mal malheureusement il
prospère mais moi c'est sur le champ
démocratique et républicain que je le
combat d'une façon radicale mais plutôt
que de parler du front jour environ n'a
envie de parler un peu de fond et ce
débat départemental
il manque un peu de fond parce que le
seul sujet c'est de savoir s'il va être
en tête ou pas et je n'ai pas su
appareils et aux européennes on avait le
même phénomène qui produisait je pense
que la responsabilité des hommes et des
femmes politiques c'est de parler du
fond du sujet du fonds départemental si
on t'avait par fesneau
monet mais c'est depuis longtemps tout
cas depuis
2007 de créer un modèle de société
d'iran comme proposez-vous là pour
l'aider par avance aurait motivé les
français les rappeler le cadre de
réflexion sur les départementales est un
peu brouillée d'abord par un de scrutin
qui a changé qui apporte quelque chose
de positif disons le quand même c'est
que la parité on va effectivement
s'appliquer dans les départements que ça
va participer dollar et la respiration
démocratique on va voir entrer des tas
de gens nouveaux d'état candidat nouveau
et là les femmes seront autant présents
dans les conseils départementaux puisque
c'est comme ça qu'ils savent qu'ils
s'appellent qu'avant que que les hommes
premier point un deuxième point on a
quand même un débat qui est un peu
tronqué parce qu'on sait pas encore les
compétences qui vont être exercés et
aller vers les citoyens pour leur
expliquer qu'il fallait il faut aller
voter pour un scrutin alors qu'on ne
comprend pas et on ne sait pas les
enjeux et ce sur quoi les départements
vont agir c'est un peu difficile pour
moi ce que je dis d'abord je suis assez
d'accord avec ce qui vient des dix je
pense qu'il faut que les attitudes
changent et je pense que la reconquête
démocratique elle va venir aussi par les
territoires et par la capacité des
territoires à se saisir de leurs
problèmes et donc ça passe par les
élections départementales ya un vrai
besoin de renouvellement des pratiques
et à un besoin aussi que les gens nous
explique je sors d'une d'un déplacement
dans des pots soutien des candidats au
départemental de fluidité entre les
structures parce que les départements
les régions les intercommunalités les
communes plus personne n'y comprend rien
les élus pas grand chose à vrai dire il
ya un vrai besoin que quand on s'adresse
à des citoyens la question soit le
service qu'on leur rende est pas la
question de la structure et la raie
manta et aurier à la en course et là
c'est une c'est un bon début écoute
entre le bon début c'était il ya un an
et on atterrit quand même dans une
espèce de flou artistique complet je
reviens d'alsace le découpage régional
dans cette région il met en ébullition
l'alsace et on verra les résultats
électoraux de façon extrêmement violente
parce qu'on n'a pas tenu compte de
l'histoire de la culture des habitudes
de travail et je trouve que cette
réforme qui devait aboutir à une
disparition progressive des départements
une fusion dans l'échelle départementale
régionale on a des régions qui sont
extrêmement grande maintenant il suffit
de penser à champagne ardenne lorraine
alsace comment on va gérer la proximité
donc il ya besoin d'aidé partants qui
gère cet échelon de proximité et donc je
touche suis pas sûr que la réforme elle
est pas encore voté au final donc on
peut toujours avoir espoir dans le
parlement elles aboutissent à une
simplification pour les citoyens pour
les élus mais il ta question d'une
suppression des départements il était
question malheureusement il n'est plus
question oui d'ailleurs avec une coupe
deuxième thème ce soir le non changement
de cap de françois hollande je ne
changerai pas de politique annonce faite
en une de nos confrères de challenge le
chef de l'état leur a accordé un
entretien dans lequel il vient il à il
entend garder le cap malgré tout les
remous de ces dernières semaines
notamment le fait de devoir passer par
le 49-3 pour faire adopter la loi macron
pour les scores finaux c'est aussi votre
avis d'abord tout c'est une drôle de
façon de présenter les choses que dire
je ne changerai pas de politique parce
que c'est introduit le doute sur l'idée
qu'il pouvait y avoir une envie de
changer seulement un changement un
changement de politique deuxième chose
j'ai l'impression qu'ils s'adressent à
sa majorité ou à ce qui lui reste de sa
majorité il essaie de resserrer les
rangs disons c'est pas la peine de vous
énerver je ne changerai pas de politique
et troisième chose me semble-t-il on a
un vrai problème sur la ligne politique
de françois hollande il a été élu sur un
programme en tout cas en apparence dont
il a complètement échappé à auquel il a
complètement échappé très rapidement
atlantis est installé et qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il est obligé la pt qui
changera pas de politique alors c'est
pas la politique sur laquelle il est élu
et qu'il n'a pas la majorité pour mener
la politique sur laquelle il a été élu
et que à l'assemblée nationale il est
obligé de passer sur un texte qui était
une avancée on l'a dit au mouvement
démocrate parce qu'il faut dire quand il
ya des avancées parce que c'est aussi ça
le débat démocratique et cas peut être
capable de le dire et donc des avancées
mineurs même la majorité de la pas voté
et l'opposition n'a pas été capable de
se mettre en ordre de marche là dessus
donc il n'y a pas de majorité pour cette
politique là et donc c'est ça qui est un
problème même s'ils changent pas de
politique a pas de majorité pour la
compagnie et donc c'est un peu difficile
alors il est ravi à 20 secondes chacun
sur cette nouvelle polémique cette
nouvelle attaque personnelle dont est
l'objet christiane taubira dont fait
l'objet christiane taubira isabelle
guinot adjointe au maire de juvisy sur
orge dans l'essonne et sans étiquette
adjointe au maire ump qui dit voilà sept
ministres qui vient de cayenne là où il
y avait le banier qu'elle reparte là-bas
vu qu'elle a toujours détesté la france
une réaction très rapide a fait nos
géants 20 secondes remet le mot qui
était employé mais moi je les plains
dans l'autre sens c'est détestable cette
façon de parler et de débattre est une
façon détestable c'est ce qui alimente
aussi d'ailleurs lente agonie za sion
dans le pays c'est ce qui alimente
l'abstention donc il faut que ces gens
qui parlent comme ça parce qu'en plus
nous montrent de tweets fait qu'on est
obligé des petites phrases on pense que
vous êtes intelligent en quelques signes
de faire quelque chose donc pour pouvoir
parler de soi et je trouve que cette
façon de parler de christine christiane
taubira est absolument d est stable et
je regrette vraiment que sa prospère
parce que quand même il ya toute une
frange qui est en train de prospérer la
tuer désolé réalise